I've been the vineagers in my whole life
and I think me and lots of other people
that I know have experienced sexual
harassment a lot especially in the city
that has these kind of a lot of
religious populations and even for some
of the secular people living in the city
they still have this very religious
puritanical orientation about women's
behavior
I was working in the market one day and
a woman came to me and started cursing
me and telling me that I'm probably
having sex with my boss and that's why I
got my job and sympathetic people in the
street think that they have the right to
tell a woman how to get dressed
I want Justin and I want to fulfill my
ride whenever I go whatever I do
the Palestinian struggle and some women
rights sake the same struggles they see
like we to demonstrate about both of
them because they connected
assaults and rapes and things like that
in college campuses are constantly
making national news and so I think
having a method for self-defense can
only be a good thing